When we factor a number, we split up the number into the product of other
numbers. 216 can be written as 2 times 108. This number is even, so I know I can
divide by 2. Then I just continue my process to get all the other factors. 108
breaks down into 2 times 54, and 54 breaks down into 2 times 27. 27 isn't
divisible by 2, but it is divisible by 3. So we have 3 times 9 is 27 and then 9
is 3 times 3. These factors are the prime factors, because the numbers only have
two distinct factors, 1 and itself. The only factor of 2 is 2 and 1, and the
only factor of 3 is 3 and 1. We can rewrite 216 using bases and exponents. We
know we have 2 to the third power, since we have 3 2's. And we have three to the
third power since we have three 3s. This is the prime factorization for 216,
since the only numbers that appear here are prime factors. Use what you know
about prime factors to figure out what's the prime factorization for 192. You
can write your answer in this box and be sure to include the appropriate bases
and exponents.